dying light is out and that means it's
time to parkour your way through waves
of undead but there's more to this
survival game than just running and
jumping here are the best tips and
tricks so you can survive another day
press and hold the jump button to grab
the ledge that you're looking at you can
easily miss if you're not having the
ledge directly in your vision to try and
keep the ledge you want in the center of
your vision you don't have to fight so
don't feel obligated to do it in fact
most situations call for you to be a
little bit more elusive and sneaky using
noise to distract them or just run away
but if you decide to murder someone be
sure and leave their Corp they'll either
have cigarettes or money or liquor or
something else that's going to be really
useful to you when you're not murdering
people be on the lookout for lockers
chests cupboards and fridges they all
have useful goodies in them and you're
going to need them for crafting check
car trunks vending machines and ATMs all
good stuff go shopping and buy yourself
some weapons you'll find the best stuff
at traitors and hubs and zones by
trading them some cash upgrades are
super valuable so be on the lookout you
can crease balance and durability or add
fire all consider becoming a night owl
although at first this is super risky
but with the high risk comes double
agility and power points so you'll level
up faster and unlock better skills just
be careful and run not only do safe
zones give you shelter so you can rest
and regain some your health back but
they're also respawn points if you die
which you will so you'll have a lot more
places to spawn and streamline your
movement through the city if you capture
those safe zones they're not as easy as
you might think but they are worth it
you have a sixth sense don't forget to
use it use your special eyes to
highlight your current objective
lootable objects within the area and all
those dangerous
enough it should be avoided ohto get
used to using UV because it's stun
zombie foes give you the
night which you need they come in the
form of flashlights and flare and
they're effective for both campaign and
multiplayer matches oh you gotta do
those side quests complete as many as
you can they level up your survivor
ranked fast and help unlock new skills
plus they give you that cash get those
air drops you can bring them into the
quartermaster and obtain rewards and
survivor rank experience night air drops
are more valuable because night is hard
you can use the environment around you
to kill things look for water puzzles
with electric wires in them all you got
to do is switch the power on and watch
them fry like bacon there's other things
too like red gas cylinders or setting
fire to a pool of oil just make sure you
don't kill yourself
I'm sorry oh did that kill you the most
convenient weapon you have is yourself
parkour is deadly and all it takes is a
bit of effort strike from above for
additional damage combine skills for new
moves and get the leg break as soon as
possible as soon as you do that they
can't move they just crawl around on the
floor waiting for you to kill them if
your sickly try eating some food for
energy its hidden all throughout the
area you have a hundred points of health
and it takes 20 for each fight so you're
going to want to keep food handy keep an
eye out on your weapons because they do
lose durability you're going to need
metal parts to repair them select as
much as you can you can't repair it
forever though eventually it will break
always have another weapon handy if your
weapon is damaged repair it or just get
rid of it it's useless in combat there's
a lot more to cover here so be sure to
check out GameSpot comm for more guides
and tips and tricks be sure to put your
own in the comments below
good night and good luck
you